good morning believe nation today's
message is ideas matter over to you
steve ballmer ideas matter I talked
about this a little bit I spoke at the
big combatant commencement at USC three
years ago and yet as I was really going
through what I needed to say to you
I have to reinforce this notion that
ideas matter people think business is
about leadership they think it's about
working hard they think it's about a lot
of things which it is but at the end of
the day the ideas that you have will
power the organizations that you join
they will create the value a great team
great energy and great hard work we'll
never make up for a bad idea now bad
ideas can also fall flat on the floor
for a lot of other reasons Windows and
the power of the microprocessor great
idea great idea and ideas matter even if
you turn around and look at your own
sort of personal lives the idea what you
choose to do does matter you don't have
to make a right choice a perfect choice
now as you graduate but what you really
need to do is constantly ask yourself am
i pursuing the right idea in my life in
my career for my company is this really
something that will create value because
at the end of the day if the idea is
wrong you will fail I agree that ideas
matter I agree that ideas are important
and creative ideas and trusting the
ideas what I would add to it is that you
have to go out and execute on the ideas
too because a lot of people have great
ideas I'm sure you guys be an
entrepreneur audience have tons of great
ideas but you have to go out and start
making progress on those great ideas for
anything great to happen because if the
idea just sits in your head
you don't do anything about it what
you're gonna find is somebody else
capitalizes on your idea right somebody
else goes out and makes tons of money
has a huge impact and you sit there said
I that was my idea that person stole my
idea where really it's on you because
you didn't go out and execute so when
you come up with this great idea you've
kind of go and start taking action even
if it's small even if it's super tiny
some tiny little step every single day
to move forward on it and you may not
have the resources or connections or
knowledge or people around you or
anything yet to make it happen but part
of entrepreneurship is figuring it out
as you go yes you can have a great plan
yes you don't just dive in and say whoa
I wonder what's gonna happen you want to
have a roadmap but you won't have all
the pieces together either and there's
gonna be a lot of unexpected things and
roadblocks that get put in your way in
entrepreneurship is about being
resourceful and finding a way around it
figuring it out partly as you go and so
if you're that person that's where
you're at right now and you have this
great idea and you think you can have a
huge impact to make a lot of money and
change the world somehow through that
idea stop waiting stop waiting for the
funding to come in for that ideal client
to come in or for whoever the win the
presidential election like none of that
matters what matters is you taking
action today and tomorrow and the next
day to move one step closer to making
that idea happen ideas matter and you
have to execute on so the question today
today is I'm curious are you guys
executing to your full capacity you've
got this great idea are you really
deeply truly honestly actually executing
on it or not leave it in the comments
below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to joseline my ADA joseline
thank you so much for buying a copy of
my book it really deeply means a lot to
me those are you watching if you want a
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot event festive
more expresso give me go